take up band because he was saying jokes
and then say and then acting as if they
weren't jokes he's a smart guy who is
also very funny and he's actually he's
actually thoughtful too and and his
mistake was going I really am this this
is who I am I am not playing a character
which he was I am this and I've embodied
this and this is who I am and this is
you're not saying anything different
from me because
if you really look at what why you got
banners because of the influence on the
impressionable minds and the reason why
it was influential is because he was
like this is real and this is how you
have this life and this is how you do
these things he's also said other things
that obviously don't get highlighted at
all but like he's worked incredibly hard
at the things that he's done and been
incredibly successful at those things it
takes a lot of dedication and discipline
to do those things the guy's smart if
you hear him
exactly and he finds a way he found a
way to hack the system it was like it
was really brilliant the way he did it I
think his miscalculation which I've even
heard him talk about is he's like now I
wish I rephrase them you never get to
the point where you can't control your
narrative and this is the problem with
having the removal of access to either
YouTube or twitch or any of these things
like going out there and getting
canceled for fun is not good because you
can't control your narrative now you've
got to go on other people's shows and be
I mean if you look at the Pierce Morgan
thing that Tate did it's like it was
this onslaught of questions he couldn't
actually articulate what he wanted to
say and you're at the whim of these
other people never get to the point
where you can't go on a platform and
reach millions of people and say exactly
how you feel about your situation you
were in a position where people trying
to mischaracterize you right you had a
million different Outlets to go out and
say exactly what happened clear the
narrative if you didn't if you were
canceled you're you're what people say
you are
also here's a very big difference right
and and I always go back to I'm like
here you know in the level that I'm at
now when I do interviews with people for
the first time and they're trying to
like figure out my past the only thing
they always you know and I always talk
to Charlotte about I said he said you're
lucky that's the only thing that they
try to they could really try to hold on
to is like the war is Chiraq [ __ ] right
and if that was my if that was an
ideology well I wasn't talking about
that no no yeah no I know but imagine if
that was an ideology that I was still
having to live to because here's the
thing with tape does Tate get that
popular without someone like it's not
what he was saying he was also packaged
he was packaging it better than anybody
that sounded like him yeah yeah that
came with a joke
that came with tongue-in-cheek comments
so again funny there's a lot of those
guys yeah so again it's like you can't
really just kind of say to him now like
well if you didn't say that back then
that's all part of why he got to here
yeah that's why I've also said and [ __ ]
I told my dudes a fresh offense I said
yo
that rhetoric is not meant for the Main
Street
that rhetoric is meant for Niche groups
for a niche group once it goes exactly
once it goes mainstream then you risk
cancellation I think that's why like
the beauty of having an art form
the beauty of having stand-up or the
beauty of having music is you're allowed
to touch these topics that are really
Radioactive in a way where people can
digest them there are jokes that I have
that are way more sexist than anything
Tate said but they're funny and it's
clearly a joke so now the information
can get out there not like I'm trying to
like push out truths or whatever I push
out comedy but when you're going this is
who I am I am this person this is my
life and pushing ideology and pushing
ideology which is very important now I
think what what Tate did is he had this
rise to fame that was meteoric right
because he was so salacious my
assumption and I would love to hear what
he has to say about it is that if he
reduced how salacious it was by let's
say 20 40 doesn't matter it wouldn't be
as fast but it still could rise because
at the end of the day he's an engaging
speaker and he's very entertaining so
it's like how do I get there while at
the same time reducing the radioactivity
of it if you look at Ben Shapiro right
so he was either trolling uh Mike Brown
or or Trayvon Martin I forget exactly
what it was but like like on the the
anniversary of the death yes there was a
troll tweet that I think is still out
there he made his bones being salacious
maybe not as salacious as Tate but it
was salacious he was antagonistic he was
pushing now he's retracted he even put
out a book where he's like we got to
hear both sides he has the daily wire
which is a news organization that is
putting out content he's become way more
mainstream palatable because his rise at
the top wasn't his meteoric yeah well
here's the thing though
in that realm you only get to like after
Kevin Samuels die you only became the
guy if you went it's hard person
you could slowly get there yeah but that
rhetoric in itself
the audience that's digesting it
doesn't want middle of the road [ __ ]
they don't want they want extreme [ __ ]
so again that's the price you pay them
for extreme no no but that's something
without art behind it if you put art
behind it you could do it but if you
don't put art behind it like the drill
music perfect example if you make art
out of these horrendous things we'll
listen to it we'll enjoy it you know
we'll we'll we'll take it in if you just
go on a pod you're like yeah I'm out
here murdering I'm doing this the police
are calling the next day what do you
mean you did that no if if
Tate didn't go as hard he wouldn't be as
nearly as big because his point is it
could be doing harder
um the dude from fresh and fit married
the way he packages it isn't with enough
comedy and with enough I would say maybe
social life a lot of it I'm not picking
on anyone but a lot of people in that
Community tend to regurgitate stuff
there I feel like a lot of us have heard
if you're old enough the thing about
Tate was it's funny in a unique way and
it's packaged in a unique way it seems
more thoughtful and seems like there's
more depth to it so it was in that sense
more quote unquote dangerous in that
it's gonna get a lot more people to be
like oh this guy's talking something
he's pivoted I think
this is a smart move by him
because one of the things he got in
trouble for was when even on Piers
Morgan they said do you really believe
your your wife is your property and
really he's trying to quote some
religious biblical historic things and
they're [ __ ] on him if he was really
like and I think that's why he's kind of
like leading into religion that he could
throw it back on religion saying yeah
how about you go to war with religion
because before he's literally they're
like wait he's explained like what
doesn't the father give away the wife
and doesn't does the last thing oh that
stuff and and there's looking at him
like so you're just saying this property
right once they get that yes you're
misogynistic yeah now he gets to say
listen I'm going by the letter of the
Quran yeah he really conveniently found
Islam oh it's perfect yeah you didn't
see the video no yeah video him praying
I I I don't know it's a good move for
him because a lot of his ideals and
things he says his philosophies matches
with a more traditional time that
usually
Islam kind of supports and here's the
genius of it you're the genius of here's
the genius of going Islam liberals will
go at Christianity all day they're not
going to go at Islam nearly as quick
bingo so if you find Islam and then you
can quote anything in Islam that makes
it seem like it supports what you're
saying even if it actually doesn't yeah
yeah a lot of Liberals are gonna be like
well I guess you know what he said he
said listen he said I found Islam
because I've realized it's the last
religion that exists
no he says Christianity ain't [ __ ]
because
there's too much tolerance so so now if
you read the scripture and it says hey
you can't be gay you'll have a gay
preacher and you'll be like oh you got
to accept everybody so it's kind of
being hypocritical he's like at least
with Islam is completely this is how you
gotta be no way else it's less time can
I say the point that I this just proves
my point one of the most searched
figures we actually said it yeah so one
of the most searched figures in history
right like there was a point in time
where he was the most searched person on
the internet oh he said any Christian
who believes in good and understands the
battle against even must convert now
he's smart man so but think about this
he converted to Islam which should be
news for the most Googled person to
convert I didn't even know why do I not
know because he led all of his platforms
get stripped from him you never let your
mouthpieces get his influence is still
up he's all over Hold On by the way he
made like 18 million on Huskies
University or something crazy like that
like he's still getting his no no he was
making great money there's no question
this month no no there's no question
he's making good money my point is he
can't control his narrative there's a
difference between making money and the
ability to control your narrative